I'm curious about the mindset of making
money and there is a massive wealth Gap
there there are people that who are
making money and some that seem to be
making more and more money and others
that are always seem to be stuck in the
ability to make money to save money to
invest money they always seem kind of
Trapped in not making it
what would you say is the mindset that
wealthy people have around making it and
growing their money for them versus the
mindset of people that stay stuck in not
making it well I I want to distinguish
there's big differences in Opportunities
yes so let's say supposing you have two
people of comparable opportunities yes
and then they were going to do that okay
the marshmallow test yeah as you as you
know apparently is you take a kid and
you say okay uh you can have one
marshmallow now or you could have two
marshmallows in 15 minutes if you don't
eat the first one yeah if you don't eat
the first one right yep okay once you
start to realize
that deferred gratification
is going to make you better and so on
and you start to count count and you say
like something like how many
days weeks months or years can I live
if I don't have money come in and you
start to focus in on that
that's the first step okay like the
marshmallow test okay so I want to save
you got to start there then if you do
that
you're necessarily going to go save in
what and then you'll start to get
exposure
to
how these things are different
okay then you start to care well I can
have one of these and one of those and
you start to experience
and then you start to learn
and basically that's what makes the
difference
that's it the so first having the
ability to have delayed gratification
then obviously diving in researching
testing and and trying different things
but
the more and more you can say you don't
want something now for a greater later
is the essential key well and what it
does then it when it comes to the money
that means money yeah now at that moment
that you don't want it you have savings
that means I want savings right okay now
you got savings so the next thing
inevitably that's going to come at you
is where do I put it
and then you get your choices and then
you experience it and you learn right